and I don't really know what my future
holds but I do know I want you in it
yeah congratulations you guys can we see
this ring first off how big of a shock
was this for you um California's been
maybe a 25 I was like completely
blindsided back doors like what the heck
is going on well I gotta say he walked
over stood you up and somebody in in on
your side of the stage was like is this
a marriage proposal and you went no and
then it why it can't be like I never
thought that that was even gonna be next
and you can't make assumptions like that
like what the heck because if it doesn't
happen you get let down all right how
did when did this un I'm gonna pop the
question to her on finale night when did
that come through four days ago probably
I want to say four or five days ago like
I had the ring I think two weeks ago but
I was like imma do it later like I mean
Christmas
but then as finale night got closer and
closer cover mom's like I having dreams
it's like I convinced her I just thought
like I mean I had long conversations
with your mom and dad like three hours
like this is what I'm gonna do like
nobody didn't stop me and they loved it
I was gonna say did you do the right
thing you got permission from the parent
to do this tonight they didn't get
permission from me but I'm very happy
what does it mean to you that he spent
so much time getting to know your family
I'm in love with that like nobody has
ever done that before and then he went
by himself so real bold
yeah okay all right what's what's next
are you moving to Missouri what's
happening I don't know moving together
if we're gonna stay here
La Missouri moving to LA I don't yeah
that's the plan
RT some of your BB 20 family has moved
out here like Rachel Winston and Caitlyn
are all out here oh my god you know
we're gonna actually move and to like a
place maybe with Hailey and Festival or
maybe by ourselves I don't know okay I
want to take it back to when you were
like this is not a marriage proposal was
there ever a second and you're like I
don't know if I'm gonna say yes right
now no there wasn't like I didn't even
have to see the ring as soon as he got
like on his knee I was like oh my god
yes like please but that's like
aggressive so I had to keep it together
you know just for like a second and he
did good this is a girl really good and
he said he got a little bit of help from
my mom I'm like I would bring brings
back to your mom and dad's like nope I
don't want it don't want it at least two
weeks in a row don't have found son I
was like that's the one oh you've got a
good one here I gotta say can we play a
little room or patrol with you usually
you sparked the internet aflame you like
said something to Haley that people are
like she ending that she's having ass
Whaley baby no babies on the way right
okay we got to focus on that we got a
wedding to plan
yeah are we gonna have a long engagement
or are we gonna jump right into marriage
you have just gotten released from the
Big Brother I'm open to either way I
don't really care but if we try to go
big or go home we might need some time
to like plan cuz it's gonna be epic
whatever it is yeah I want to come can I
get it no no but yes please come are you
gonna put some of your BB 20 family in
the wedding party yes for sure I'm not
even gonna go with names but Haley is
gonna be there rockets and ball danger
yeah so everybody else I don't know
but we'll see we gotta figure out what
the budget is how many people were
inviting all there's a lot of things in
there Robin cast we don't know cast this
show she's the one who made this love
match happy
yeah there's so many that are coming the
other little news of the night Casey
just one big brother yeah I'm excited
like that's my girl I'm happy I could be
the vote to bring it home for her like
she killed it the game like well-rounded
everybody loves her and she was a piece
of competition so she deserves it hands
down shoutout to Casey how they talked
her too much
but shutout her alright would you guys
come back and play again do an all-star
season and I didn't get the plaintiff
beat oh so yes they were like really
intimidated by us so yes we need a power
couple season get you two back in the
game final two I would love that
we put on the universe alright I think I
gotta let you guys go okay we're gonna
play as Christopher Knox
alright well I look forward to my
wedding invitation congratulations